cette ville est maudite et ils ont fermé
résident clark avec ce jeu avec
médecins
le temps est venu pour la fenêtre
les sorcières de zugarramurdi commence par
un vol un groupe de personnes en haillons un
groupe de perdants parias sociaux
Ils attaquent un magasin qui achète de l'or dans le
Puerta del Sol sont déjà là alors
on les aime tout de suite beaucoup car
C'est une idée que nous avons tous eue.
quelque fois
prendre toutes les alliances qui
ils sont là cachés enfin ils en ont fini avec
25 000 anneaux déguisés en statues
vivant de la porte du soleil, ils
ils pensent que c'est la meilleure façon d'appeler
l'attention
malheureusement la petite amie de l'un des
ils volent la voiture avec laquelle ils allaient
va-t-en
la chanson ma copine s'est levée dans le
ruelle
donc ils doivent prendre un taxi
et aussi malheureusement le chauffeur de taxi
occupé il y a un homme à l'intérieur
Je pense que je devrais le télécharger comme ça
beaucoup plus calme
un homme qui veut La Havane j'ai
appeler oui ou oui j'ai été appelé par
un boulot là-bas et ça rend tout difficile
beaucoup mais ils arrivent à arriver
pratiquement en france
eh bien ne le chargeons pas final d'accord
nous avons changé les plaques d'immatriculation oui nous avons
armes cachées si le sac sac le
des bagues que tu portais dans le
Sur le chemin, ils rencontrent des sorcières
ça ressemble à une malédiction
secret quel état
désolé pour les heures gênantes mais non
Ils auront vu une femme plus âgée vêtue de
cheveux noirs et longs lâches non non non
c'est ma mère, elle manque de risques, non
il ne fait aucun doute pourquoi voler 25 000 bagues à
l'or est plus sacrilège que voler le coffre
de l'alliance
un
Mme
les sorcières sont la juste punition pour leur
arrogance ignoble et indigne
silence, le temps est venu
vengeance